[Music]
my grandma
loved collecting all these jugs and jars
in our tiny home
this was back in shanghai where i was
born and our family of five
was living in a 550 square feet
apartment
despite the physical limits grandma
would exhaust
all the algorithms to optimize every
single ancient for shelf spades
so that all these containers could
somehow snuggle
in our kitchen cabinet this is a picture
taken at my fifth birthday and you can
see just about
five percent of our total kitchen
collections right there in the top left
corner
we would then use these jars and jugs to
go get freshly ground soy milk from a
local grocery store
or use them to hold spices and tea
leaves and seasoning
all year round when asked
why don't we throw them away grandma she
always smiles back at me and says
there is no away and everything
has a home
now i think my grandma wanted the
five-year-old me to know
that it's a policy scheme to think
everything we throw away would just
magically vanish
we have to be mindful of our waste
footprint on the planet
because after all it is our only home
now my grandparents lived through
poverty in china in 1930s
and they had to live their life under a
conservation mindset
because of economic constraints
we live in a very different time now but
her words
there is no away stuck with me
i'm here today to talk trash because i
believe
her mindfulness of waste should be a
value that we preserve
across generations and geographies
fast forward to today i feel like i'm
disappointing grandma
every time i get an amazon package so i
ordered this for my friends couple weeks
ago
and this tiny thing came in a huge box
with these bubble wraps
now raise your hand if you ever felt the
same way
i know a lot of you do and you're not
alone
this is to show you that i too fall prey
to the modern consumption model and in
fact
one million single-use bottles are
consumed globally every minute
that's enough to fill up an
olympic-sized swimming pool every two
minutes
more than 80 percent of these plastic
waste
are just burned or landfilled because of
a mix
of misaligned incentives lack of
education and insufficient
infrastructure
for material recovery
under current rate of consumption there
will be more plastics than fish in the
ocean by 2050
and the story doesn't end there once
exposed
plastics degrade captioning not
available we're literally
changing the way earth looks and there's
no such thing
as a way a waste garbage patch in the
middle pacific
awaits gilroy california 50 miles from
here
away as the landfill sites next to the
lowest income population in indonesia
and away is the food water
and air that we so depend on every
single day
so now you may be wondering i know this
is bad but
what should we do to change the course
waste is a design flaw and we should
work together
as a society to correct the flaw
consumers businesses governments and
non-profits
we each have a role to play in this team
sport
as business leaders we're uniquely
positioned and empowered
to make skillable impact by creating our
brands into agents of change
so i'm going to focus today's talk on
three levers
that business leaders can use to design
out waste
across the value chain lengthen product
lifecycle
increase operational efficiency and
extend producer responsibility
and the good news is designing out waste
can translate into short-term and
long-term economic gains
let me tell you how first
the post-pandemic world presents an
opportunity for businesses
to shift our economy away from take make
waste let's not make this crisis go to
waste
out of the pandemic consumers will be
savvier than ever
by choosing quality over quantity
functionality over disposability
and value over price
to appeal to this shifting demand
towards
value-based consumption businesses can
look into investing materials
and products that are inherently more
durable and recyclable by nature
in addition we can create incentives and
mechanisms
to engage our consumers in reusing and
recycling the products
by lengthening that product life cycle
we're adding more touch points
along the customer journey and thereby
strengthening that relationship
and building brand loyalty
casing point patagonia successfully
launched the campaign
called don't buy this jacket for black
friday to raise awareness about buying
fewer but better
they also made repair the new fashion
through their one word program
that collects second-hand clothes and
gears
second waste to some extent
means loss of efficiencies in the value
chain and missed opportunities for cost
savings
this is why it makes most direct
economic sense to design
out waste for example
food waste is a 400 billion dollar loss
globally
a company called afresh is targeting the
food waste problem
in the perimeter of grocery stores they
use ai power technologies
to optimize the quantity of fresh foods
ordered every day into the store
as a result they've saved up to 20
million pounds
of food waste and helped grocery stores
increase gross margin in produce by 40
percent
lastly just like any externality
problems
there is a way to use market force to
correct the flaw
and in our case these measures are
called extended
producer responsibility laws or epr
in the u.s california is actually
writing a ballot
to tax producers of single-use plastics
business leaders should proactively
embed these epr
measures into our core business strategy
because again
social norms are changing and
regulations are catching up
doing nothing is no longer a viable
option
here's an example of how companies are
doing it
a small number of environmentally
conscious beverage companies in the bay
area
such as straus and la vie are committed
to collecting back their bottles for
reuse
these programs are core to their mission
to reduce
waste footprint of their products from
end to end
last year more than 50 of the largest
consumer package goods companies
signed the us plastics pact to commit
to a hundred percent reusable recyclable
and compostable packaging by 2025.
it's a step in the right direction but
we need a lot more investment in access
education technology and infrastructure
to make it a reality
as business leaders i want us to
challenge ourselves
to reinvent the business model by
lengthening product life cycle
increasing operational efficiency and
extending producer responsibility at the
end of the day
what should matter to all of us is that
we leave the world a better place than
we found it
a place where waste is no longer a
design flaw
a place where we can proudly tell our
grandkids
there is no away and everything
has a home thank you
you